Trey, my daddy Joe Rogan
podcast by night all day here.
Put this hat on and take a
picture with me. Here it is.
Eddie Bravo, Tony Ferguson,
Habib number. Go metal off.
Holy Shit. Holy Shit. This
is the couple of weeks away.
You're going to be there for
that Eddie to be awesome.
It's going to be fucking nuts, man.
Dude, we're doing getting mean. Tony is,
that's,
that's an exciting fight man.
I know we can't talk about
strategy but um, it's uh,
it's crazy fight between the number one
and the number two contender in that
division.
The obvious strategy for Khabib is to try
to take Tony Down and obvious strategy
for Tony is to keep it up
and got him up on his feet.
That's the obvious and everybody
knows that. Let me think.
How much do you think,
uh,
like opinion changed when he got clipped
by Michael Johnson and got wobbled?
People are saying, and I mean if you're
looking at, I mean it's pretty obvious.
Okay. He, he, he, he's human.
Yes. That's really what you saw.
How he saw as exactly cause for 24 fights,
five or 23 fights before that. Right.
[inaudible] and motherfuckers
basically sad guy.
He's not one of those guys
that can take anything. Right.
You know there's guys out there
that can take any shot. Yeah.
They haven't been rocked yet. Right. We're
seeing a little, maybe a little chink,
a little tiny Cenk. Everybody's
looking at that. You know what I mean?
It's going to give people confidence,
but he's so good at taking
people down and mauling him.
You know that that is the hardest
thing to stop. But you know,
we're doing everything we
can to prepare for the best.
The worst, the worst case scenario,
the best center we're, we're doing not,
I mean Tony's doing everything really.
Tony is a fucking,
he's a maniac is the most fascinating
fight in the division for me outside of
Conor McGregor versus I beat those
two fights. Conor McGregor versus IB,
even Tony Ferguson.
Versa could be.
Those are the two most exciting
fights that in my opinion,
without giving anything away,
everybody knows based on the past
that Tony can seriously choke people.
Anybody out like any in any wrong move
on the ground and he could hit that Doris
from any position and he just,
it just keeps growing and
growing and expanding and he's,
he's become so unorthodox on his feet,
on the ground is pulling guard, flying
him a nice, he's all over the place.
He's doing gymnastics. He's doing
flips. He's doing, he's doing
what he's doing. I don't even really know.
I tried to do it in big bear. I'm like,
ah,
he doesn't steal bowling ball and he
does all this crazy like almost like
dancing does with it.
It looks like you brought a
wing Chung dummy up to big bear.
He's into wing Chung. He's into
everything. Everything man.
He is a true side. That wasn't like
a joke that when he's really into it,
he likes, he trains, uh, like
no one I've ever seen before.
It just hours and hours just
out in the front up in big bear.
He built everything, the bags, the
stands, everything. He builds everything.
He's got a house out there.
He's the ultimate macgyver. No,
he rented it and built it the first
two days. Brought it all out, dude.
He's like the ultimate macgyver,
a construction carpenter
McMahon would take down.
Just seems so damn do when I
put my hands on her, you know,
like when I put my hand when
the interviewer her back
is like glaze and t bowels.
Yeah. She she gorilla.
Yeah. She's stupid. Strong,
strong woman's stupid strong Olympic
silver medalist. Right? Yeah.
See this. Here's Tony working
with that. The weighted ball.
It's just so what a
weird way of working out.
Like he does all these
strange moves with it.
Like did you ever ask him like what
his philosophy is? Philosophy is, uh,
obviously he believes in
movement training, you know,
cause this is all just like
some crazy yeah. Capa where uh,
but with a steel ball, he's
co doing this all day. Yeah,
he does just, we always
just mixes it. Oh yeah.
He's always doing something for
people trying to sync this up at home.
It's round one. I'm sorry I didn't
do this for the first fight.
Round one three from tron over three 50,
two,
three 50 triangle task. That's
a wrap. Sam. Sara McMann.
He just pumped that girl Bass Gorilla
squished her. Yeah. You know what?
She's helping her.
Maybe she may be the first girl Jesus
that's known for taking people down,
passing their guard and choking
him out like that that go to,
you got to stop that fucking,
what did she say?
I don't know. What the Hell is she
saying? She's fucking scary. Yeah. Yeah.
One of the girl does that take some down
passes that garden chokes on can choke.
She could be. That could be
your shit right there. Well,
you know she got tagged by Amanda Nunez.
Choked out herself like her stand up.
She has power and it punches.
She's a big power puncher,
but she doesn't have the kind of power
that Nunez as Nunez is going to be a real
problem for post guys.
She might not need it.
The way she closed that arm triangle.
It's so professional. She's, she could,
she could take most girls down and because
of a ruffling she understands she's a
finisher. She can't keep her
husband's a Jiu Jitsu black belt.
Yeah. Isn't he a, I believe
he's a Jujitsu instructor.
She did it from the mount to yeah.
Very interesting.
I saw total she's pumping that grow up.
That's what she's doing.
He's coach telling her she's going
to be going to be all right. I had,
I had some doubts about her early cause
she said some things about Jujitsu.
When she first came out to the UFC,
the judge, she didn't like Jujitsu.
She doesn't train digits
or something like that.
She was like old school wrestler type
of mentality. But it looks like she uh,
finally, um, had our mind opened, you
know, that was some good, that was good.
Solid guard passing wrestlers just don't
pass God's like that unless they train
Jujitsu, you know, wrestlers, some
wrestlers never learned how to pass.
The guard kind of seems like
that's a thing of the past
though, doesn't it? Yeah.
No,
exactly.
That's why I was kind of worried cause
she would say something like that.
She was saying, I don't train
Jujitsu. Go wait a minute. It's 2017.
Everybody needs to train Jujitsu.
If you're fighting in the UFC. Yeah.
Do you have to love it?
I never heard her say that.
Did you would see if you can just sign up.
When did she say that it?
Was it like real early, early on, man.
She did say something that she,
something to the effect that
she hasn't liked Jujitsu. Well,
my, I guess being early, early and
it's an old school wrestler mentality,
that's all. No big deal there. She ain't,
she ain't the only one like that. Exactly.
There's still Russell's like that and
there's been a bunch that were famous to,
well,
there's a always a bunch of people that
get super attached to their style that
they started out with and you want
to prove that I don't blame you.
I don't blame. The rest was,
look what happened. Hawaii's
shows up. Everyone, these,
these Midwestern wrestlers
are looking at this.
Who's this little Mexican kid choking
everybody out beating us and they're,
they're doing challenge matches and
great. They're like, fuck these guys, Huh?
How are they going to take me down
and do that shit most, you know,
most of the rest of his that I ended
that are like that. They don't,
they do that because they're fucking lazy.
That's what it says.
That's what it is because they're,
they're,
they're so good at
wrestling and they just,
I just seems like it's just a,
it's a,
a weird like lazy thing for one because
it's extra work in too because you're
going to get fucking choked out.
Investors don't want to lose, right.
It's that kind of thing where it's hard
for wrestlers to progress. Hey look,
I think it stems from,
it stems from the Gracies coming out
challenging everybody and beat him.
Getting wrestlers. Uh, Dan,
Dan Severn gets choked out.
Mark Coleman's coming in more homeless,
wasn't trying to pass the guard.
He was trying to beat
Jujitsu to hold you down.
But it also stems from the
same thing is with kickboxers.
Kickboxers don't want
to train Jujitsu either.
I mean that was always the
problem with certain fighters.
They just didn't want to get tapped
because still good standing again.
That's from the UFC cause you also saw
the strikers getting taken down easily
and getting choked out easily.
So right away dude has been
training 15 years striking thinking,
fuck these Jujitsu guys.
Fuck though.
I want to learn a little take down the
fence. And I'm a fucking knock 'em out.
Well that's learning it.
Fuck learning. And I'm alert.
Some take down the fence and I'm still,
I'm going to still knock us cro cop.
So I mean back in the day not to stand up.
Even this whole,
even this whole thoughts on the cage
and his training in different, you know,
you're like, no man, you,
and then that was wrestler versus striker
that that rivalry when you eat gorge
bulb changin fought Mark Kirk.
Are you kidding me? That,
do you remember how that fight went down?
Mark Change can cracked them. Yeah. Yeah.
Mark and mark curb took him
down at will and then got tired,
would never pass the guard.
Never tried passing the gods above.
Changin had a decent guard.
He had a good survival guard.
He had good guard recovery
and Mark Curtain, uh,
admittedly never worked on passing.
He just felt that he could just
stay on the garden pound somewhere,
but you couldn't do it.
Devolved chance involve changin kept
tying them up and then late in the round,
late in the fight,
he couldn't take them down anymore.
They were both on their feet marker was
folded and that's when you go to vote.
Changin lit him up. Remember that?
It was very interesting back then.
If marker would have just spent day one,
once he decided to do MMA, let me get
rid of their passing and mountain. Okay.
But we'll, but in all fairness,
that was the least of his problems.
That guy was on a million different drugs
that documented this smashing machines.
Crazy or it didn't matter. I didn't find
out what exactly he was doing. Like, whoa.
Like that guy was fighting the toughest
fighters in the world while he was
shooting heroin. I mean, he was,
he was shooting like all sorts
of Carol and I didn't know that.
Did you ever see this smashing machine
who shooting up opiates shooting now he
was. It was all pharmaceutical
grade. You know,
painkillers raised all the steroids
and stuff. Crazy documentary.
You never saw number this. Yes, but I just
remember the steroid part. That's all.
That was nothing. He was slamming
painkillers and it was fucking veins.
And he just sitting there and
letting them film the whole thing.
Like fucking yes, exactly what I
was describing for. But you know,
fresh bottles of whatever
painkiller he was fucking taking,
but judging a straighten his arm,
it's,
they thought when they were filming
him that they were filming the baddest
motherfucker on the planet earth
and they were like, oh my God,
we're watching this guy
right as he falls apart,
like right as the filming started
beginning, he was falling apart.
Here it is Tony Ferguson.
So here's the sleep, boom.
[inaudible] boom. What's going on? It's
going to be very hard to take down.
And if Khabib takes him down,
he's gotta be really worried about them.
Chokes that we've already seen. Yes.
So He's, he can just take down Tony,
like he did Michael Johnson and not worry
about legit chokes from all sorts of
pricing. It's, it's all in the
transition. So it tends to,
in great Marcella teens, if he raps,
he's always looking for Darcy. So, uh,
could be, you know, he's one of
the best grapplers in the UFC.
No doubt.
He may be the best at at grounding and
pounding and controlling you like a,
like a legit high level black belt.
He passes.
Who knows how it's going to
match up against Tony Man.
But we're preparing everything we can.
We're doing everything we can.
I don't know how it's going to
look when it's all said and done,
but we're doing the best we can to
prepare for the worst case scenario.
Who knows what's going to happen.
But uh,
the one thing's for sure is one mistake
on the ground and Tony's going to wrap
your neck goes yes, but this
motherfucker as well. I mean,
one mistake on the
ground and Habib number,
good Madoff's gonna fucking break
your Ross. He's, he's a freak.
And that's why this is so an interesting,
because Tony is a freak too.
And like when you see Tony fucking up
Hofeld dos Anjos here. I mean, man,
Tony Ferguson easily could have been the
UFC lightweight champion of the world
if he caught Hofeld
Dosantos when dos Sandra's
had the bell, he coulda
got 'em and you know, Tony,
I think Tony could do that to anybody.
How did the, how did he beat, um,
Barboza was he, did he just choke Barboza
yes. Yeah. He dashed him, right? Yeah.
That was it. Right here. I'm standing
and I'm finished him off on the ground.
It was perfect.
Tony.
Something special and that's why this
fight is so interesting because hubby was
obviously something special.
He's the only guy that's in a,
a contender that has been fighting the
best guys in the world and is undefeated
as you fight for the title. That's
so unheard of. Yeah. One or two.
Everybody's got early in their career,
they've got a fight or two that they lost,
but he's one of the very few guys that
has only shown one moment in his entire
career inside the octagon where
he really didn't look so good.
And that was a brief moment
where Michael Johnson hit him.
Obviously he recovered from that and it
came back to that mashed him smashed out.
He just,
when he gets guys on the ground,
it's almost like he's a
different weight class than them.
Yeah.
There's levels,
thousands of levels of being heavy
and he's super heavy sticks on.
He's a great guy. I saw him in
person at my fight. That fight,
the law supposed to happen is passing a
big his passing to from full guard or to
like open guard right into he
forces a m a z guard or a quarter z.
Like right away there's movement to set
up the half guard that he's going to try
to pass. Brilliant. His knee slice is
brilliant. Uh, his mount is control.
That crucifix move, man. He's
a black. Everybody knows it.
Very few people do it. Yeah, he's, he's
always looking for it and obviously he's,
you know, if you look at his earlier
fights, he's got triangle chokes.
I mean he could finish off your back too.
Yeah, he's right. So that's a tall order.
Tall order for Tony.
But believe you me,
Tony is looking pretty damn good
to me right now on the ground.
So it's going to be crazy.
What is he and how it all plays out.
Yeah. I'm so excited for that. I'm,
my head's going to explode.
Yeah.
It's a crazy fight and it's,
it's going to be more crazy for you just
got so much invested in it. You know,
for me as a guy that gets to
sit there and call that fight,
I'm fascinated just because when you
see a guy like Tony Ferguson, you know,
he's a problem.
Like how do you solve that problem?
Like what's the solution to that problem?
And um,
I don't know what the answer to that is.
You know,
I would say a guy who can keep the fight
standing up and tee off on him and land
good strikes like maybe a guy who takes
advantage of the aggressive style,
that number go Madoff has, but
you know, maybe Tony's that guy,
it's going to be interesting
as, as um, Michael Johnson show. You can,
you can punch him, you can't hit him.
If you can land a good shot, you can
rock them. And I think that, you know,
that's going to be the main place to
catch him. But if you can catch him,
keep on the outside,
you know,
you don't want a guy like
that who fights at that way,
that good at grappling and that could
arresting and take downs and constant
pressure in your face the whole
time he got to keep him outside. No,
I think it's only tall enough
to do it because again,
seeing how small could be was
last weekend I was like, man,
he's not that big of a guy.
You know? I'm a huge fan of it.
I think he's fucking awesome. Bobby
think whiskey walks around big 75 maybe,
maybe, you know, he just didn't see,
and you know how the Russians traveled?
They're always in groups
of fucking a hundred. Yeah.
So it's always entertaining and they're,
they're fucking hilarious.
But he just didn't seem that big at
all. I was like, wow. Huh. So that was,
that was the only thing that
shot him because he's so strong.
Okay.